let's discuss this dramatic event with
Fox News national security and foreign
affairs analyst Walid Phares Michael
Pillsbury of the Hudson Institute and
Mike Fuchs a senior fellow at the Center
for American Progress all right Mike
Mike Fuchs let's start with you
I was curious as to see how the left was
gonna cover this tonight because they're
all on you know stormy Daniels are on
their you know usual policies and
stories of resistance but this really is
something we'll see what ultimately
happens but the the huffington post home
page has like a mock you know Trump and
a mock Kim jong-il and I guess from the
Olympics to impersonators that's the
best they could do well look this is a
great step forward the diplomacy that
President Trump has signaled the u.s. is
willing to do with North Korea is the
right step this is the direction that
many people have been calling on
President Trump to take for more than a
year now I'm happy to see that he has
done it he got there because he's talked
tough here because he played a you know
pattycake with Kim Jong on he said you
you come near this country with a
nuclear weapon we will destroy you
that's basically we sit and although
people on the Left were like how do you
do this is you're gonna thermonuclear
war what are you doing they were going
crazy with it one tweet abut I have a
nuclear button they went nuts on that
but maybe that's the madman theory
correct Michael Pillsbury I mean you've
been writing about this for decades and
I know you're very skeptical because
like me you've seen North Korea pull a
fast one on like this before but what do
you think so far well it's time to
celebrate a great victory when it
happens and you're quite right just in
the last two hours the mainstream
left-wing media has been beside
themselves and this really can't be
happening or they don't really know how
to explain it it wasn't purchased
there's no concessions the American
exercises can continue for the next two
months the entire set of conventional
assumptions about North Korea's gone out
the window series of sound bites by the
I this I loved calling it the experts
the experts the experts said the experts
predicted here's some headlines USA
Today analysis how Trump's nuclear
button tweet could jeopardize his
foreign policy news week well Trump and
Kim's game of nuclear chicken blow up
the world
Republic this is not a North Korean
crisis it's a trump crisis well we take
it away
look they have the critics have focused
on the president's tweets what they have
missed is everything else they did not
see that the task forces were
surrounding North Korea did not see they
were putting pressure on China that we
are mobilizing Japan and South Korea
that we are winning the game at the
United Nations Security Council even
with Russia and China not videoing a
resolution against North Korea it was
well-crafted but they missed a big game
michael Fuchs do you believe that the
president will meet Kim Jang on here in
the United States will they meet in
Seoul what if you have to guess right
now where they would end up meeting I
mean this is gonna be wild if the
meeting actually ends up going forward
look I think that is actually the big
question right now does this meeting
actually happen some senior officials
from the White House have already
refused the state when exactly before
may actually happen but press secretary
senator Sanders did not say she said
time to Beadie to be determined and so I
think the big question now is what is
the plan we have rushed on a complete
180 from talk of potential war and
military conflict was to get on the
table that was a summit but to Summit me
I so I do think that our real question
now is what is the North Korean game
here and what strategy does the United
States have to actually extract real
concessions from the north well I think
we've already extracted some concessions
Michael Pillsbury I mean we had
Madeleine Albright clinking champagne
glasses with Kim jong-il we had George W
Bush do his best we had Barack Obama
John Kerry shell diplomacy nothing came
of it except North Korea got farther and
farther along with this nuclear program
Russia and China both acting as semi
proxies in North Korea sending
technology of food supplies fuel most of
that not all of that was shut down and
president Trump pushed hard against the
Chinese you wrote the bore of the book
about the hundred year marathon about
China how does China play in here I
think they're equally surprised as we
are that
Rocketman that's his old name we publish
it and use that anymore Big John fan I
understand Kim jong-un so he took it as
a compliment it was called Rocket Man
the Chinese didn't help him
but they helped a little so they're
gonna try and take credit for this as
much as they can I think this whole plan
began during the transition I think it's
been well thought-out president Trump
when he was campaigning did not make
North Korea his number one issue he did
it after the transition and I must say
that according to the press secretary of
defense Jim mattis was very nervous and
cautious Tillerson was always trying to
say were nervous and Nellie's Trump's
like I got it don't worry me neither
they were very nervous about this whole
thing well lead I've got to say the
president made it clear to his advisors
that the way we had been going about
this for four decades wasn't working and
he made it clear to them the reporting
tonight that we wanted a we wanted a new
path forward give me the options how can
we help how can we break this old path
in path and pave a new way forward and
at least so far it seems like there's
been some success what I understand
Laura is that the essence of this plan
is to let the North Korean feel that
they are completely isolated that even
the Chinese are not going to help them
no other Russians as I said on the
Security Council they were not even able
to get any vote for them but there is a
missing point we are not singing here is
what the North Koreans and the South
Koreans have already spoken about and
the messenger the National Security
Adviser
of South Korea who announced this mass a
message he most likely will brief the
administration about what is they in a
head and michael Fuchs when you look at
where we've come from and this North
Korean issue it's been one of the most
intractable diplomatic national security
geopolitical challenges the country's
ever had I said during the their
campaign Michael Pillsbury I know you
did to that North Korea was the biggest
problem it wasn't it wasn't Iran it
wasn't Iraq or Afghanistan
but change it wasn't climate change it
was North Korea it purely if the fact
that they don't know this guy's guy
seems like a you know cuckoo for cocoa
puffs but he has nuclear weapons and you
destabilize that region China gets
involved again we're back in a war in
the Korean Peninsula and you know that's
not going to end well for anybody that
but this is intractable Trump I mean
it's madman theory I mean if I'm a mad
but you don't know what I'm gonna do I
mean maybe it is the madman theory well
look i think that this again is real
the big question and we have to be very
clear-eyed about what can be
realistically achieved here with North
Korea because of decades of really
difficult experience with North Korea
and getting tried getting played many
times over with the North Koreans so we
need to be very clear-eyed about what
can be achieved with diplomacy which is
why I asked the question what is the
Trump administration strategy now with
their gonna tell the Center for American
Progress what the strategy is but
Michael boo I don't think tell any of us
but Michael what are the pitfalls here
you've written about this extensively
give me that give me some advice for the
president and his team going into this
situation well they need to understand
what the North Koreans are up to I think
they do I have a lot of confidence in
president Trump's team but the main
thing is the negotiations while they go
on which could be a year or two will
result in a freeze of both nuclear tests
and missile tests that happen so now
time is on our side so get it right yeah
don't rush it to a conclusion get it
right gentlemen fantastic panel you guys
all came in at the last minute we really
really appreciate it